I think that's why that's one of the
things that a lot of people don't get
why Boris one two terms in London he one
two terms in London who's London's very
African and the African Diaspora
identified with him a lot he does quite
well really yeah the African diaspora in
London identifies with Boris Johnson if
you like parents if you like it so not
the young Woking so you won't ask about
like this if you anyway anybody under
the age of 25 probably not Bob ppapi B
and beyond that definitely and I think
that it's one of the things is that the
largest population of black people in
the UK at the moment is of African
direct descendants and that's a massive
coup for the Conservative Party if they
want to go into that so they've already
good this is why the difference between
the Indian diaspora and the Pakistani
aspera the Indian diaspora is always
very much voted within the Conservative
Party because of that whole point of
aspiration a lot of the Pakistani
community that have come over here I
like you know we're not were were were
people to work in the mills and certain
places so they've always stayed in
labour areas and kind of than those are
the kind of conversations a lot of them
in Scotland I've now gone towards the
SNP ironically but ultimately the
African diaspora is very conservative
and they are very aspirational I think
all come under especially when it comes
with Jeremy Corbyn they've all fled
countries where the ideas of socialism
czar he's selling at the moment have
actually crushed their consonants so not
that I work with the Conservative Party
or not like you know but I think I can
oh like they would do really well on
everything of black MP we in the
Conservative Party's African nobody ever
sees that like every black MP within
because everybody's African that's
interesting that's very interesting
change cleverly Sierra Leonean
interesting oh I never ever thought
about where people come from but that's
what I mean and I think that's what I
mean about like cultural identity and
conversations and the whole point is
just because you become poor become a
refugee tourism and so my life was a
little bit like coming to America but
the other way around
I mean I finally think I mean you're
looking for cliking there a bride we
were but we deal still with like my
mother was still turn up as though she
like entitled to the same [ __ ] she
did when I have family around the
country
[Music]